[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長です君たち数でストリーミングでしてますか
そうそれは世界一臭い食べ物ですと良いね実際にそのシュールストレミングスが今家に
あります
こちらですーるストリーミングです
一応ネットでは本当に危険なんで開けるときは室内ではいけないでくださいって書いて
あるんですけど
あまゆ avaya ないまったくもって病な甘い
くさいな普通ですとネーミングです強みずつ手に身を発酵させた復興スウェーデン電動
が発酵食品発酵食品です講習が強烈なので野外で開館してください
絶対しませんとですねっとではだいぶ話題になってて動画は結構あるんですよその手術
リビングスを開けてみたみたいな食べてみたとかこうなんかみんなどうするんですけど
結局皆外でやってます見ての通りすごい8個中でも膨らんでるんですよまじで世界一
臭いてるものらしいです
なんで今日はねまぁ実際に俺が猫そんな外なんて行くのめんどくさいんでも部屋
中でやりますするストリーミング片段でか言うして全部平らげたり俺が方こんなので
美味しいでしょ
たヴェローナおいしい所質に考えて
で終える
食べるのは
潰れ所かもよ
さすがに部屋では無理なので浴槽でいます
というわけでですね8 shoes 都営 wings 衣服に付いたら取れません
唯我なのでご完全に手袋をして全身完全防備で今回は行きますが別も恐れているのは
というハザードみたいなさ如意が強すぎて
俺のアパート中学さんになっちゃってるから怖いから一応ね
小新西とかもめっちゃ準備してあります常総資材をたくさん用意しておきました
そしては受けていきましょうでは早速描けていこうと思います
さあでまだ遅いんですけどゴール
2ターン目
me
power air
うわぁ
んだーどうぞ
パンッ
何を言った
さあ取ったら今後2 f のこちらが世界一臭い食べ物です
ブーッ
4つくらいうんっ
ドラマでば10キロたのでうーんねー
当然本当に弱いん
eme
あるた意味でう
にゃううーんなぜだけ
ん
ちょっが走らない者一覧
やっぱ big e
ウール大
俺ちょっとゼロで開けただけねーうわぁ秋鮭狙った
うわぁやばいですけどこれを食べなきゃダメですけど全部選んで一口で管理して
ください
[音楽]
ああああああ
ua 俺はこんなにいます
これは未来やっぱ日本製をとばったりたいんでー
俺はそんな高い向けて津田れると思う
ええええええ
ていません
努力ガッツリいきます
文のゴッドあ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ん
とって